>> HAPPY THANKSGIVING.
>> Tucker: AND TO YOU.
IN AN IDEAL WORLD PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES WOULD COMPETE OVER
WHO IS BEST REQUESTED.
-- QUALIFIED.
WE LIVE IN A CARTOON WORLD.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN A RACE TO
ADOPT THE MOST ISSUES IN
CATEGORY YOU HAVE NOT THOUGHT
OF.
>> A WHITE GUY SHOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT.
>> TO BE MORE THOUGHTFUL GOING
FORWARD IN WHICH I TALK ABOUT
OUR MARRIAGE AND I ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CRITICISM I ENJOYED WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
>> MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE, HER AND
HERS.
>> MINE TOO.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
JASMINE A JOURNALIST FROM NEW
YORK CITY.
-- CHADWICK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK ABOUT
TWO OF THE GUYS ARE OUT.
THEIR WOKENESS DID NOT SAVE
THEM.
THAT SHOULD MAKE ME HAPPY OR
SAD?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
[LAUGHING].
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IN THE
END THAT THE WOKE THING HAS ANY
APPEAL OUTSIDE OF YOUR OLD
NEIGHBORHOOD IN BROOKLYN?
>> NO, UNLESS YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT DONORS AND THE LBGTQ
LOBBY.
CHINA IS NOT SHAKING IN THEIR
BOOTS BECAUSE WE WANT TO GIVE
FREE SEX CHANGES TO ILLEGALS
UNDER PRESIDENT WARREN.
>> Tucker: WAS THAT A PROPOSAL?
>> SHE MENTIONED WE WILL HELP
TRANSGENDERS ILLEGALS AT THE
BORDER.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
IF OUR DIVERSITY IS OUR
STRENGTH, THAT'S A SHOW OF
FORCE.
>> [LAUGHING].
I THINK CHINA'S MONOLITHIC
CONTROL OVER THEIR PEOPLE IS
THEIR STRENGTH.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS GOING FOR.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> THE DEBATE AFTER THE LBGTQ
TOWN HALL IT WAS AN EPISODE OF
JERRY SPRINGER, HAD A LOT OF
AMERICANS CRINGING.
THEY ARE SHAPE SHIFTERS IN.
OHIO THEY WERE MODERATE AND NO
LBGTQ STUFF CAME UP IN THE LAST
DEBATE.
>> Tucker: I THINK THE AVERAGE
PERSON WATCHING AND EVEN THE
AVERAGE REPUBLICAN, I AM NOT
AGAINST GAY PEOPLE.
WHAT DID WE SIGN UP FOR?
PEOPLE GRABBING THE MICs AND
SCREAMING AND TALKING ABOUT
BIOLOGY THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
>> BRINGING CHILDREN INTO IT.
MOST AVERAGE AMERICANS DON'T
CARE.
THEY HAVE A LIVE AND LET LIVE
ATTITUDE.
MAYBE EITHER THEY ARE TONING
DOWN ON THE WOKENESS.
THEY DOESN'T START OFF THAT
WAIVE.
THE DEBATES HAVE BEEN CALMER.
-- WAY.
NOW THEY ARE FOCUSSING ON INSANE
POLICY BY GREEN DEAL.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T IT WILL
EITHER.